شهراني يحددان مصير ميسي وخمسه عشره حقيبه
تشعل الجدل زيدان يخطط للعوده الى التدريب
عبر بوابه السيده العجوز وهلا يرتبط رسميا
بصديقه الطفوله هذه الاخبار وغيرها ننقلها
لكم عبر قناه العربيه رياضه واسعدوا
بمتابعتكم
[موسيقى]
اشعل الارجنتيني ليونيل ميسي حاله جدل
كبيره على السوشيال ميديا خلال الساعات
القليله الماضيه بشان مستقبله الذي لا
يزال غامضا حتى اللحظه وصعد تقارير تؤكد
اقترابه من مغادره باريس سان جيرمان
الفرنسي عقب نهايه عقده الصيف المقبل
الانباء تؤكد تواجد ميسيم عائلته حاليا
ببرشلونه في زياره سريه باب التكهنات فتح
بعد معرفه اصطحاب البرغوث لخمسه عشره
حقيبه حتى اللحظه لا شيء مؤكد باستثناء ان
برشلونه لم يتمكن من استعاده البرغوث قبل
حل مشكله الرواتب فهو مطالب بخفضها لنحو
200 مليون يورو
ننتقل الان للحديث عن زين الدين زيدان
مدرب ريال مدريد الاسبانيه السابق
ومستقبله الذي لا يزال موضوع نقاش دائم
خلال الفتره الحاليه الصحف الفرنسيه اكدت
اليوم ان زيزو يرى نفسه في ناديه الصادق
يوفنتوس ويميل الى فكره خوض تجربه التدريب
في الدور الايطالي واوضحت انه في الوقت
الذي يتم فيه الحديث عن رغبه باريس سان
جيرمان الفرنسي بالتعاقد مع زيدان الموسم
المقبل الا ان الاخير لم يرد بشكل ايجابي
على هذه الانباء
نتحول الى انجلترا وتحديدا مع الذي يبدو
واضحا سيره على خطى ميسي حيث يعيش حاليا
قصه حب مع فتاه نرويجيه تدعى ايزابيل جوه
انس ثنائي نشا سويا في مدينه باجن
النرويجيه ولعب لنفس الفريق المحلي الذي
مثله هالاند في بدايه مسيرته الصحف
الانجليزيه رصدت لهما صورا اثناء التسوق
امس اعلنت وبحسب تصنع فقد قامت صديقه
الطفوله بحذف كل حساباتها الشخصيه على
مواقع التواصل الاجتماعي
لضمان الحفاظ على خصوصيتها وخصوصيه هذه
العلاقه التي تبدو جديه
الختام مع مغني للراف مجهول الهويه يزعم
انه لاعب في الدوري الانجليزي هذا المغني
اطلق اغنيه على منصه اليوتيوب اخفى بها
هويته بقفازات وقناع من الورود استطاع من
خلالها اثاره فضول المتابعين على السوشيال
ميديا الجمهور توقع ان يكون لاعبا في نادي
لندني خاصه ان اغلبيه مقاطع الاغنيه
المصوره هناك ووصل الامر لوضع قائمه
باسماء اللاعبين كزاها جونسون
لكن الاسم الذي اجمع عليه بفضل وشم وتصميم
شعر اللاعب هو ايدينيكاتا لاعب ارسنال
[موسيقى]